vous êtes sur rtl
avec nous en studio l'un de ceux qui ont
été reçus ce matin par edouard philippe
bonjour bruno retailleau bon jour qui
sait robert vous êtes le président du
groupe l'est républicain au sénat
que vous a dit le premier ministre n'ont
pas grand chose il nous a écouté et il a
consciencieusement noter ce que nous lui
disions mais je ne peux tirer aucune
conclusion de l'entretien d'un peu plus
d'un quart d'heure donc vous n'avez
aucune idée de ce qu'il compte faire et
deux sur quoi ils pourraient lâcher par
exemple non mais en tout cas je lui ai
dit que la première chose à faire parce
que au début de cette protestation
française pas seulement les gilet jaune
les français les soutiennent massivement
il y avait ras-le-bol fiscale on ne
répond au ras-le-bol fiscales non pas
par un haut conseil au climat mais en
annulant la hausse de taxes est ce que
le sénat a fait et je lui ai dit j b
aujourd'hui il ya plus de hausse puisque
le sénat de la supprimer
est ce que ça veut dire que la semaine
prochaine à l'assemblée vous allez
redéposer un amendement pour que
l'assemblée revote des taxes est ce que
c'est ce que vous voulez auquel cas ce
serait l'explosion bien sûr en france
donc je pense que le gouvernement devra
dans les 48 heures annoncé qu'il renonce
à cette hausse de taxe en 2019
oui mais cela va-t-il suffire c'est tout
le problème c'est que on a tellement
tergiverser que le front de la
protestation s'est élargie s'est
diversifiée il ya une confusion aussi
parfois dans les demandes on le voit
bien là après deux représentations
mais je pense que il ne suffit pas de
faire un discours de la méthode
gouvernement dit le prison république
dit mais on a péché parce qu'on n'a pas
été pédagogue s'éveilla pas besoin de
pédagogie pour expliquer 1 française qui
a une taxe les français savent
parfaitement ce que c'est une taxe ou un
impôt il faut annuler cette hausse de
taxe
il faudra aussi et je lui ai choisi faut
un référendum comme le souhaite laurent
wauquiez par exemple prendre la parole
aux français comme il l'a dit moi je
pense qu'en tout cas il faut se poser la
question parce que aujourd'hui en france
comme dans toutes les grandes
démocraties occidentales les classes
moyennes qui constituent la colonne
vertébrale de nos démocraties ne se
sentent plus représentés elles ont le
sentiment que ceux qui les gouvernent
son temps sa cible à leur souffrance et
font des choix différents de leurs
propres choix je pense qu'il faudra qu'à
à côté de la démocratie représentative
on puisqu'on se vouent
et je pense qu'un gaulliste comme moi ou
comme d'autres ne peut pas l'exclure des
moments de référendum sur des sujets qui
sont des sujets importants je pense que
c'est une réflexion de long terme qu'il
faut mener
je pense que jma à référendum dans
l'immédiat sur on ne sait quelle
question d'ailleurs quelle pourrait être
la question parce que c'est compliqué de
trouver une seule question face à cette
crise lanvaux qui a précisé que ce
serait sur la fiscalité écologique mois
n'écartons pas cette idée du référendum
sur des points des grands choix de
société que nous avons à faire sur
plusieurs sujets structurants
il ya aussi un autre sujet c'est que
depuis quelques années on voit bien
qu'en france on ne peut plus manifester
pacifiquement
il ya une atteinte aux droits
constitutionnels à manifester moi je l'
ai vu à nantes avec les à dist le
gouvernement a donné raison aux à dist
contre la justice contre la démocratie
et aussi contre les élus faut pas
s'étonner que aujourd'hui il ya des
règlements et c'est à nantes qu'on a vu
les premières manifestations hyper
violente avec des gens qui sont très
mobiles qui se casse qui se masquent le
visage
au sénat nous avons fait voter une
proposition qui permettrait justement de
donner un arsenal judiciaire au juge et
aussi aux policiers pour que nous
puissions comment dirais-je essayer de
faire en sorte que nous ayons une
réponse beaucoup plus ferme à ce nouveau
type de violence parce que sinon on ne
pourra plus manifester pacifiquement en
france et je trouve que c'est absolument
grave les policiers le demande
il faut les écouter et pau et pour
l'instant ce n'est pas suffisant mais
vous pensez vous que c'est une sorte
deux à dix qui ont manifesté la danse à
paris non la proposition la propre
exemple la proposition en tout cas on a
vu le creuset le nez saccage des centres
villes de nantes et de rennes se sont
opérés par les mêmes modes qu'on a vu
par exemple à paris et qu'on a vu aussi
le 1er mai alors je ne sais pas si c'est
le black block d'aider à 10 soit ce sont
des gens qui ce casque qui se dissimule
le visage et donc vous avez des
interpellations et au bout du bout vous
avez très peu de réponses judiciaires
pourquoi parce qu'on n'arrive pas à
prouver leur identité est le lien entre
l'identité est l'acte le délit qui est
causé et bien nous proposons par exemple
que désormais le fait d'être masqué dans
une manifestation violente
ça ne soit plus une infraction mais que
ce soit un délit puni d'un an
d'emprisonnement et
15000 euros d'amendé j'avais dans une
manifestation quand on se masquer le
visage c'est pas parce qu'on a peur
d'attraper des coups de soleil
merci bruno retailleau d'avoir été
l'invité de rtl midi je rappelle que
vous sortez un de matignon vous avez été
reçu ce matin par edouard philippe